so sorry I didn't Google you I didn't
Wikipedia I'm aware of that you're a DJ
you're in books I mean these are
information that I already knew you mean
that I know that for a couple years you
did something else right we don't have
to talk about it but I have to say that
I know I have to say though that I have
masturbated to you I was waiting for
that and so it's you know cuz we've had
AUSA obviously on this podcast many
times and I for some reason I knew saw
show that's not [ __ ] I knew awesome when
she was um 16 or 17 what yeah before she
was a Dom at the time no she was in high
school flyers for a comedy club oh wow
so I was playing The Laugh Factory and
she and Jamie Masada goes eh buddy you
know you know Asif and also was like the
16 year old Japanese girl she was and we
passed out flyers cuz no one bought
tickets to my show
and we were on New York City just like
you know just passing our tickets and
then I just said to this young girl I go
let's go on a roll a little got a little
roller coaster and one of the things so
we did that and we had some candy and
[Laughter]
that sounds bad yeah but yeah but not in
a it wasn't molesting candy yeah it was
on ship can it was friendship kids candy
you know there's two types right while
lusting and then there's friendship one
yeah so I gave her some really just
Christian chip yeah I think it was just
like the candy corn okay that you get at
Thanksgiving you know it's very simple
and you know or the bracelet yeah we do
Frazee Halloween yeah yeah
well it's the same same color couple
months you guys are ganging up on me and
I definitely talk to any court on
Thanksgiving so like people it's the one
no but
yeah yeah yeah I do like candy cause I
did when I was a kid I wouldn't just
pure sugar sugar okay that's in the
shape of corn kernels mhm it kind of I
guess bigger bigger yeah yeah yeah it's
not a flavorful I love sugar same thank
you have a problem so with with I've
never masturbated to awesome because of
the fact that um there's a family
dynamic you know to do that you know I
mean but with you I didn't know you so I
feverishly one time sorry babe this is
before I made I'm so sorry you don't
think that we've I she's not only for
men feverishly yes she she's a goddess
she was the biggest thing yes you what
you were like the top person right for a
minute for a minute yeah yeah but then
you got out of the game
I did yeah yeah